it's not what you know it's who you know
is that what everybody says I want to
kind of change it works for me and
hopefully will work for you because
really that's why I make these videos
hopefully somebody can take something
out of it you know I'm not trying to
preach or anything like that I just
wanna help if I can and so I actually
think it's not what you know or who you
know but where you know where you go
it's really where I want to go with this
to me
there was never what I knew or exactly
who I knew I wasn't actually that
amazing at networking in my Wine Library
retail business part of the world if you
can believe that as much as I love
people we're a small business that I was
working so hard every hour just to build
the business I didn't have time to
schmooze after hours because there were
no after hours I would work until 9:00
or 10:00 p.m. it's actually where are
you going that I think is most important
what was successful for me and what I
think will always be successful for me
and I think for many other peoples I had
a very clear understanding of how far I
wanted to take this which is very far
and I haven't even begun even though a
lot of people now friends are coming out
of the Woodworks and a lot of you know
different people are like oh you're so
successful congratulations all this
stuff to me I'm just a stage one of a
long journey you know I'm aiming for
craziness are there are there tools to
be paid are there are there tough issues
that are happening because of it
absolutely anything insane has a price
and I've met a lot of interesting people
who just want to build a company sell it
and go fishing and I think that's
awesome
I think it's awesome if you know where
you're going I think where you're going
so what who where because once you get
there even though it's not gonna taste
as good as you think I know that for a
fact everybody knows that you kind of
were able to position yourself to go
there you know to you know it's kind of
like Nick Cannon McKinnon kept throwing
out there I'm gonna marry Mariah Carey
it happened he went there I think it's
very important if you're building a
business a community you're working on
something whatever it is that you're
doing please before you do anything cuz
gosh so many people have been rolling up
on me lately and telling me things and
pitching and talking and I get it and
it's awesome I love to hear it
the majority of people have no idea
where they're going they understand why
they're doing it they understand what
they know they understand who they know
but they don't know where and I think
once you know where you're gonna weigh
them I like how I said why once you know
where you're going you're gonna win